watching buy my book book won't you take  a look look look I talk about what I'm  from from from my crazy mom mom mom what  can your viewers and fans expect from  the book what are some revelations are  gonna make in the book well from my book  I love if you want to know I just how  did you get started and they they don't  know they want to know some personal  background I'd give it to him so any of  my exes just don't get the book I feel  the teeth and I'm like you know the one  that left me yeah you and nan you in it  so all my exes and there's a lot of him  I do talk about that and just how i get  to got to this point it's a lot of frogs  so you met that prince yeah some ugly  toads well we are excited about the baby  thing oh you're gonna see more of you on  YouTube yeah I hope to see you again  when I happen baby yeah bring the baby  over to ET that's Robbie baby's first  interview